ρίζω των κύριάκω και μεταναχραθήκα ου είχαν και κάποιον αξίωμα για παράδιμοαυτό είναι συνέβηκα πάρα
πολλές φορές και νομίζω καταλαβαίντεις στους λόγους πολύ θέλαν να δείξουν τον αστωπο πρόσωπο α
πούμε εκμεταλλεύοντα στη τηνικών αντιδική μας ας πουμε κιι δυσκολές οη μεγάλες που εόσον και
αντο προετή μασαμέσα μου ήταν των περίόδον που κοίνωσε ότι σταματό ενώ προετήμαζα το έδαφο
στο μετά πάνω που ο διο χρόνια εναι έναι εύκολο να πει τέλος και τα
πρώτεο ενάμιση χρόνο τανήμουν και στην κύπρον ρταη στην κύπριο μετακόμησα σίγουρα πέρασαν μιας μορφής
κατάθληψης νόμίζα ότι οιμονο ξεχάσαμεκλείσαν οι πόρτες ενμουνα ποδιεκτώς και ακόμα και που την κοινωνία
ακινομίζειζ ότι βραλον τα πόθηκα μου ότε πλέον είδα ακόμα και σήμερα ας πούμε κυκριοφρό
στοστο δρόμο και ενι να δω κάποιοσε να μο ενδοήσει ο αρι του βοήθησεμε νανεντακθώ
καινιώσω ότι όχιμου κάποιος σημαντικς ότι είμαι αποδεκτός και ότι του άε στον πρόσφερα κάτι
και κάποιάιο καξεθάνουντ ότινο γιαενοείτα ότι και πολύ άλλοι ανθρώποι πουστο χρον του αθρητισμού ή
σε διάφορα λ παγγέλματα και λοιπά τα οποία ήμου ήμου να πό δευτές αλλά σίουρα
συνέβηκε και ότί τον πουλέμε ότι κάποιο και μεταλευτήκαν το όνομν τη χάρησου και για
να γιαδικά τους προσωπικά όφελη επε σπριγα το θέμα των υποδομό θέλα ρισογάτι εσε ένας
έμπυρος αθλητής γνωρίζει στων ανθλητισμό από πρώτοχαρι έτυχε να σε πιασει κάποιος να ση οποί
ν αντιλέφωνα όπ τα κύρί να πόλα σου πω έλα κάτω στο τάδε γραφείο να
δούμε πως μπορούμε να αυτιάξουμε υποδομέ οι αθιλητές αν εσένα που εππέ